we can always do it again
wow
wherever you look it's clear britain's
response to russian aggression is about
to get tougher
it's going to be a busy eye
this downing streak today signaling they
are not going to leave the question of
what now unanswered for long are you
going to toughen up sanctions prime
minister
nobody in politics wants to be seen
underplaying the threat from president
putin will the prime minister work
across the house
to ensure that this is the end of the
era of oligarch impunity
by saying that this house and this
country will no longer be homes for
their loot the uk was the first to call
out what president putin was doing in
ukraine we've been instrumental in
bringing the world together the western
world together in lockstep to deal with
the uh the problem but actions have
consequences unfortunately i think we've
also now got an upside risk on energy
prices from you know from worst things
happening in ukraine does pain for
vladimir putin mean pain for people here
at home if we um crank up the level of
sanctions it is going to be difficult
there's a real challenge i think for
european countries as a whole to get
ourselves off of using russian oil and
gas do you think that the people of
scotland are prepared to pay a personal
price to put pressure on vladimir putin
over a conflict that's not exactly on
their doorstep yes i i think they are
because i think the people of scotland
have got enough wit and wherewithal to
realize that if you tolerate this then
who is next is there a price here at
home to standing up to president putin
foreign secretary
one cabinet minister involved in the
discussions about ukraine told me they
weren't unduly worried about the impact
here in the uk of the west going toe to
toe with russia
but with the prospect of higher energy
prices meaning higher inflation and
sanctions hitting the stock market which
can affect pensions there will be costs
and today yet more
ministers told regulators to take timely
and transparent action against russian
state broadcaster russia today if
they're found to be spreading
disinformation now it seems this channel
rt international is in the crosshairs of
westminster
but closed down rt in the world service
could be hit with tit for tat
retaliation
everybody wants more nobody going soft
on president putin but actions do have
consequences sam coates sky news
westminster